we've been talking a lot about
elasticities of demand so you were
probably wondering can we think about
elasticities of supply and as you can
imagine the answer is of course we can
and it's interesting to think about how
does the quantity the percent change in
quantity supplied relate to percent
change in prices so for example let's
say we have a lemonade stand of some
sort so this is price on that axis
that is quantity on that axis and let's
say that our supply curve looks
something like that obviously the higher
the price the more quantity we're
willing to supply and let's say at a
price of one dollar
at a price of one dollar the the
quantity supplied is going to be 10 and
this is going to be in gallons
gallons per week
so the quantity supplied is going to be
10 gallons per week and let's say that
if the price
goes to
two dollars
so when the price goes to two dollars
the quantity supplied
quantity supplied goes to
goes to
16 gallons per week so what is the
elasticity of supply
roughly over this period right over here
so the elasticity
elasticity of supply and you can imagine
how we're going to calculate it's going
to be the percent
change
in
quantity supplied
supplied
over our percent change
in price
so what is our percent change in price
well we went from one to two dollars
so this part right over here is going to
be we went up by one dollar
so we went up by one dollar per gallon
so it's going to be up by one dollar and
we don't use one we don't use our
starting point as our base like we would
do in when we're traditionally finding a
percent change because we want to have
the same percent change whether we go
from one to two and as from two to one
so instead the convention when we when
we think about elasticities is use the
midpoint of these two or use the average
of these two so one plus two is three
three divided by two is one point five
so it's one over a dollar fifty or you
can see a dollar fifty is right in
between these two things and one over a
dollar fifty this is about this is 67
roughly so this is approximately 67. we
have approximately a 67
change in price based on how we just
calculate it remember we're using the
midpoint as our base
and then our percent change in quantity
supplied
percent change in quantity supplied
that's this so this right over here we
went from 10 to 16. so we had plus six
over a base of midpoint between 10 and
16 is 13. 10 plus 6 is 26 divided by 2
is 13.
6 over 13 which is going to be 40
something percent
get a calculator out so we have 6
divided by 13
gives us 46 percent so this is this
right over here is 46 percent so we have
when we had based on the way we
calculated a 67 percent increase in
price we had a 46 percent increase in
quantity supplied
so this is a 46 percent increase in
quantity supplied and so we can see it's
going to be 40 our elasticity of supply
is going to be 46 over 67 percent so
it's going to be something less than one
we can get so that's going to be that
divided by
point it's actually 0.6666 it keeps
going on forever gives us to 0.69 so
this gives us an elasticity of supply of
0.69 and maybe i could say that
approximately
0.69 which tells us that we get a we get
a smaller percent at least at this price
point right over here we get a smaller
percent change in quantity supplied than
our percent change in price now let's
think about like we did with when we
thought about the the elasticities of
demand let's think about different
scenarios
so let's think about let's think about a
scenario that is inelastic this may be
perfectly inelastic so let's say that
price
and quantity
so
let's take let's take me for example i
make videos i love making videos this is
what i want to spend my days doing and
and i don't care how much you pay me or
or how little you pay me i guess if you
paid me enough that would maybe i'd
spend a little bit more time making
videos but let's just assume that i
don't i'm completely i you know whether
you pay me a penny a video or zero per
video or whether you pay me
a thousand dollars per video i'm going
to just make the same number of videos
every day
so this is this right over here is
videos
videos per day on average and this is
the price per video and let's say no
matter how much you pay me whether you
pay me nothing or you pay me a thousand
dollars
i am just going to produce on average
let's just say three videos a day
so then you have this
right over here you have a perfectly
inelastic
perfectly inelastic supply curve so this
is perfectly
perfectly
in elastic
supply curve
now you could have the other scenario
you could have the other scenario where
you are a farmer
so let me do price
and quantity now you have the other
scenario where you're a farmer and you
can
you can you can either do crop a or crop
b maybe it's corn and wheat and you can
easily swap between the two and let's
just assume for simplicity it costs you
the exact same to produce one or the
other so in that situation
so let's say that the price of wheat per
and let's say we're using comparable
units so the price of wheat
wheat
is
for you know adjusting for units and all
of that let's say it's ten dollars i
don't know for per bushel or something
like that
we just want to simplify it for the sake
of our model right over here but this
right over here we're thinking about the
corn we're thinking about corn
we're thinking about corn
and so if corn
so if
let's say corn is right at 10 and it
right at 10 when they're both at ten
dollars i will produce
so let me make this clear
so price of corn
price of corn is ten dollars and the
quantity of corn maybe i know i produce
i produce two thousand
bushels and i know these prices are way
off for what the real price per bushel
of corn or wheat is and same thing
my quantity for wheat right here is 2
000.
now if the price of corn were to go
marginally up if the price of course let
me put this so this is our graph for
corn so this is ten dollars and this is
2 000 bushels per year or something so
let's say that's where we are right over
there
now if the price for corn goes
marginally up if the price for corn goes
up to even ten dollars and five cents
per bushel all of a sudden i'm going to
shift all my wheat production to corn
production so this is going to go to
zero and then this is going to go
to 4 000. so then we're going to go so
just 1005 we're going to go all the way
to 4 000.
and likewise if this price were to go
down if this were to go to like 9.95
i would shift all my production to wheat
and i wouldn't produce any corn and so
there you see that we have a very the
the demand curve is getting very flat
and you can see based on very very small
percent changes in prices i have very
large percent changes in quantity
supplied so this right over here is
approaching this is approaching
approaching
perfect
perfect elasticity huge changes in
quantity supplied elasticity for small
percent changes in price
now the cool thing about elasticity of
supply is it's actually much easier to
make a curve that has unit elasticity or
even if you want about a constant
elasticity but if you want to have unit
elasticity the easiest curve i can draw
for unit elasticity
is going to look like this well actually
this is the curve for unit elasticity it
will literally be a curve that looks
like that and the reason why it works in
this case is because it's upward sloping
as price increases so does quantity
increase for the supply curve so at any
point here the two are going to be
proportional so a given change in
quantity and a given change in price
they're going to represent the same
percentages because as price is
increasing when this is when you have
large price or when you have medium
price you have medium quantity when you
have large price
you have large quantity
so these steps are going to be the same
percentage of either one of them when
you have small prices you have small
quantities and so it's much easier to
construct a a curve
a supply curve that has unit elasticity
than it is to construct a normal demand
curve that has unit elasticity